Київ -smartcity, де дієsmart card -єдиний квиток на усі види транспорту.
Ця ідея команди мера Кличка киянину Філіпу Альїду дуже подобається.
Але йому геть не подобається її реалізація.
Їздити по картці можна.
А от поповнювати  в цих запечатаних або вимкнених автоматах на більшості станцій метро неможливо.
Стільки збоїв в ньому, стільки недоліків,
що інколи мені просто соромно за те, що я купив цю Kyiv smart card.
Філіп - громадський активіст.
Упродовж останніх двох років своїми запитами до КМДА та міськради
вимагає від чиновників звітувати, чому повна реалізація проекту постійно відкладається.
На думку Філіпа, в багатьох планах мерії щодо осучаснення транспортної інфраструктури
присутній фактор поганого менеджменту і політичних інтересів:
показувати дії напередодні виборів.
Активіст побоюється, що єдиний е-квиток нормально не запрацює і в листопаді,
як це обіцяє команда Кличка.
Адже КМДА наразі зайнята політичною боротьбою з командою нового президента.
Новий уряд вже прийняв рішення про звільнення Віталія Кличка
з його другої посади - голови Київської міськдержадміністрації.
У разі затвердження цього президентом, головою КМДА може бути призначена інша людина.
Якщо це різні люди, які ще в конкуренції між собою, то, на мою думку, будуть очевидно контри між ними.
Я не вірю, що це може до хорошого, до конструктивного призвести.
Втім, новий прем’єр Олексій Гончарук переконує киян,
що навпаки розділення повноважень допоможе покращити систему управління столицею.
На переконання команди президента Зеленського, Кличко втратив над цим контроль.
В мене немає жодних сумнівів, що в Києві не припинилася корупційна практика,
і в Києві досі існують групи впливу, які насправді дуже сильно,
надто сильно впливають на діяльність адміністрації.
Тому, я думаю, якщо підсилити пана Кличка сильним головою адміністрації,
менеджером, який би був здатен опиратися оцим всім групам впливу,
то це дуже гарно відіб’ється на інтересах пересічних киян.
Мер Віталій Кличко відкидає усі ці натяки на корупцію,
вважає рішення уряду таким, що порушує закон про столицю.
Цей закон передбачає, що посаду голови КМДА займає лише обраний міський голова.
При цьому Офіс президента запевняє, що є й інші норми законодавства,
які дозволяють президенту призначати голову КМДА.
Але це, на переконання мера, призведе до руйнування самоврядування.
Йде політична боротьба за контроль над столицею.
Самоврядування у Києві слабке і руйнувати нема чого,
вважає експерт Реанімаційного пакету реформу Юрій Ганущак.
І ця слабкість, на його думку, закладена саме в нормі закону про столицю,
де посада мера об’єднана з посадою голови КМДА.
Ті, хто придумав формулу суміщення, думали, що це буде потужний симбіоз.
Насправді це суперечить здоровому глузду і навіть теорії управління.
Тобто людина, яка вранці приймає рішення як мер міста - розпорядження коштами,
адміністративні якісь рішення - після обіду вже одягає кашкет представника держави,
в функції якого є контроль за тими рішеннями, які він прийняв вранці.
Втім, спроби команди президента змінити цю ситуацію без зміни законів,
на думку експерта, приречені на провал.
Наразі не можна бути у наративі,  що ось давайте замінимо дракона на дракона!
Управління столицею може бути просто заблоковано
через постійні суперечки між мером та головою КМДА.
На думку підлеглого Кличка, першого заступника голови КМДА Миколи Поворозника,
наразі це може призвести до зриву опалювального сезону,
неякісної підготовки бюджету на наступний рік.
Чиновник взагалі не розуміє логіки Офісу президента.
Адже, в його розумінні, закон про столицю не передбачає, що голова КМДА
зможе втручатися в усе, що робить мер або міськрада.
В нас в усіх є якась хибна думка про те, що в нас
цю роботу можна розділити.
В нас на 95% - це все робота місцевих органів виконавчої влади.
Те, що стосується державних функцій - це виключно частина освіти і медичні субвенції.
Більше нічого державного нас в місті немає.
Все решта - це місцеве самоврядування.
Земля, нерухомість, дошкільна освіта будь-що, що є в Києві,
воно знаходиться в розпорядженні Київської міської ради.
Роботу Київради мер не зробив ефективною і в загалі її не контролює, кажуть в  Офісі президента.
На останній сесії, як і багато разів до того, зібралися не всі депутати, навіть не було кворуму.
Мер Кличко, схоже, вже готовий до позачергових виборів.
Я ініціюю консультації з головами депутатських фракцій
і груп про дострокове припинення повноважень Київради.
Водночас правляча партія "Слуга народу" готує новий законопроект про столицю,
аби уникнути проблеми поєднання усіх повноважень в одній особі.
Активіст Філіп Альїд вважає, що інститут КМДА взагалі треба скасувати.
Це те, від чого треба відмовлятися
на користь створення реального місцевого самоврядування в Києві,
створення  виконавчого комітету, де кияни будуть впливати на виконавчу владу.
Саме цього вимагали від команди Кличка впродовж останніх 5 років багато громадських організацій.
На думку активістів, влада, маючи величезний бюджет в майже 60 мільярдів гривень,
зробила недостатньо, аби позбавитися проблеми поганих доріг, ненадійних мостів,
хаотичної забудови столиці, яка відбувається часто з порушенням законів.
В активістів багато запитань до команди Кличка і з приводу оновлення комунальної сфери,
відсутності навіть реально діючої системи роздільного збору сміття і його переробки.
Чи дійсно команда президента хоче не просто позбавитися Кличка на чолі Києва,
а покращити самоврядування за рахунок повернення тих же райрад, системи виконкомів,
опитані DW експерти і громадські організації не впевнені.
Адже законопроект "слуг народу" про зміни в законі про столицю може бути прийнятий терміново
без проведення широкого громадського обговорення,
оскільки мер Кличко заявив, що готовий оголосити дострокові перевибори вже цієї осені.